thanks so much for joining this episode
guys we love making this stuff to bring
all types of people together we do this
topic in a previous middle-ground
episode but due to your feedback we
chose to bring back this topic with
teens and parents I do not know each
other also if you want to be in a video
because I love reading your stories
still at the casting horn below enjoy
one of the biggest things I believe in
is you don't need a mother you don't
need a father you need a parent my name
is Anthony Cabasa I have three children
and I'm a veteran and I'm a parent and
I'm happy to be here my name is
Cassandra Roy I am a life coach and I
have one son David Alexander who was a
full time MFA student at Yale University
on a full scholarship
my name is Marissa gold I have two
children they're 13 and 10 and I also
have a parenting company I run social
and emotional empowerment groups for
tween and teen boys and girls I'm
Elizabeth I'm 18 next year I'll be going
to school to study nursing and I have
two dads and a brother my name is Adam
I'm 15 years old and currently I'm
working on starting my own clothing
brand I'm Noopur I am a computer science
and engineering major at UC Irvine I
feel too stressed
the first source of stress in your life
is probably your parents something from
your parents and it kind of with your
parents expectations it kind of builds
at least for me it did my parents
immigrated from India and so they went
to college India and I'm a first
generation Indian American I did
robotics like the music I did
volunteering in high school and I got
into college they were like you should
finish college in like three years like
yes it's four years but finish it
earlier save money do a master's program
finish master's early try and do a PhD
get a job while you're at it I don't
even think I would be in college if it
wasn't for my parents but the fear of
disappointing my parents is terrifying
if I wanted to pursue something else I
would do it after college I would do it
after I got a job stable after I've
fulfilled what I needed to fulfill for
my parents it pains me to hear how
stressed you already are because I think
as adults like we know like it doesn't
ends you know it's like it just like it
gets harder and hard like unfortunately
unfortunately like life gets exciting
and it goes in dips and waves and
whatever but like there's no alternative
you just keep going there's no option to
quit I felt like the last kid being
chosen for the baseball team don't be
too hard on your parents because they're
doing the best they can with the
information that they have and in terms
of you I would really strongly suggest
that you sit down and have a
conversation with them because you may
not understand this but they know
something's not settling with you my
parents have tried talking to me the
walls are already there and if you don't
have the foundation it's hard to start
at a later age I have struggled to be
honest with my family
I mean I was in the closet for 13 years
so that was one thing it's almost like
as soon as I came out of the closet
everything else did I started being more
open I talked to more people I learned
how to express myself to art and through
clothing which I'm now doing for me
personally I have struggled with an
eating disorder from the time I was 11
until just recently I mean you're always
in recovery if you have an eating
disorder so much of that mental illness
is lying and going behind people's backs
my parents had to sit outside of my
shower at night to make sure I wasn't
throwing up they had to check in with my
friends to make sure I was eating all of
these things there was an absolutely no
trust and I still couldn't feel like I
could tell them anything because my
mental illness wouldn't let me I have
worked so hard to regain all of my trust
and now my parents trust me to
absolutely no end they know I will tell
them the truth in any circumstance in my
family we don't talk about mental
illness or depression or anything like
that we don't talk about sex and my
family saying the word sex in my house
is like taboo and slowly my dad has
tried reaching out but it's various like
sivan like he once told me in high
school hey you should go into this body
positivity workshop in school like he
could tell that I wasn't happy but the
way I looked I couldn't ever really come
out to them about the fact that oh I had
depression oh I'm going to see a
therapist in college now I think for me
my struggle with being honest with my
family is that growing up I was
Christian and everything was solved
through prayer and reading the Bible if
you were depressed prayer and Bible if
you wanted to have a girlfriend hey
that's not allowed prayer and Bible my
mom was a very fierce female individual
in my life her motto has always been
your life is going to suck all the time
and if you set that baseline then you'll
never be disappointed because you always
expect the worst by growing up that way
I feel like maybe I'm a stronger
individual but that communication was
never there and the honesty was
definitely not there because there's
things that I would do and I'm like well
that's definitely not Christian like so
I'm not gonna
that what I hope to instill in my
children it's like hey no matter who you
are who you love I'm not gonna be like
my mom where she's like no you have to
be this perfect inside of a box person
personally I've gone through the same
thing but now I know that I can tell
them and absolutely anything when I
first started telling my parents that I
was having sex
I was never met with that's horrible you
need to stop you're not a good person
none of that the first response was
always thank you for telling us let's
you know provide protection just in that
scenario I knew that I could be honest
with my parents and absolutely anything
moving forward but it was hard to tell
them that as an adult as a wife and a
parent the truth was always the best
weapon for lack of a better word to lead
with because it cut down on her to cut
down on pain I cut down on frustration
have I always been honest of course not
I'm human I like to think I've been
honest about the stuff that was
important but I've learned that honesty
is in fact the best policy it's just
easier all around for me social media
can be very positive
I honestly think that social media and
the Internet in general has probably
been one of if not the best thing in my
life having no like queer role models
and seeing no it's just the expression
around me in the real world where I am
but discovering all that through the
internet I would not I found out I was
asexual without the internet I would not
have known what asexuality was I would
not have even known that was a word
because at least in school and at home
we never talked about this I was like a
little bit like okay is it more positive
than negative but I think I'm gonna use
like butt to my own testimony like how
it's been for me I started a social
media page under the alias conservative
dot Latino and I get a lot of hate mail
and I get a lot of people calling me a
race traitor calling me you know a fake
this I fake that they call me names they
wish death upon my family and my
children and I see a lot of the profiles
didn't even have pictures and then I go
to their profiles zero followers zero
pose zero nothing and I'm just like man
these people yeah exactly somewhere
they're mourning and people they bought
yeah exactly I used to play video games
and at some point I actually decided to
use my voice in a video and I am a
female in a within the video game
community and there's a lot of masculine
toxicity every single day guys just hit
on me I was 15 years old and these guys
were like 20 30s they would like gift me
games asked to let me out and usually it
was fine I can be always be like no and
most of them are respectful sometimes
they would escalate they were done and
to find out where I lived they would
threaten to rape me the point that I
realized I had to like get away from all
this is when someone threatened to rape
me and I actually got scared
yeah and this is exam eeen couldn't be a
better illustration of a parent's worst
nightmare when it comes to social media
right and how quickly it can escalate
and especially like you are 15 which is
pretty young but they're they're kids
boys and girls that this is happening to
when they're 8 9 10 they have no idea
how to handle it and they don't know how
to even talk to their parents about it
because they innately feel that there's
something off but they also feel like
they could get in trouble if they bring
it to their parent and I'll be honest
like my daughter
has been asking me since she was like
six can I please start a YouTube channel
can I be like that's been her dream but
I go on these articles and I'm hearing
about like all this online bullying and
especially with females I feel it's a
larger thing because I was like a youth
pastor for my old church and a lot of
them would tell me that day if they're
on social media they would be receiving
elicit pictures from grown adults so I'm
like scared I'm terrified by at the same
time I feel like I feel like I'm almost
punishing my daughter when she does
start to explore that I would say don't
take it away because that's gonna make
her angry and she's gonna find a way to
go on it anyways cuz there's so many
access points for social media yeah
that's why I like I'm just like very
concerned because as a social-media
influencer I see what I get in my DMS
and I see that's type of content that
people leave on my and I would never
want cuz it's probably part of why she
wants to do it cuz she sees her dad
doing yeah you know I mean the kids want
to do what they see their parents doing
your job to do any of the teens here
feel that sometimes your parents are
hypocrites for phone and social media
usage I see more texting while driving
in the parents generations they don't
know about that technology that I call
I'm just gonna check this really quick
and that's what causes a lot of access
oh yeah on the steering go I'm dead
serious it's real it's really bad he
doesn't understand that you can leave
people on read like you don't have to
respond to people in the moment if my
parent texts I always just feel like I
need to reply write that in there I'm
just like no parent OCD for sure more
than I'd all the time I wish my parents
listened to me more
[Music]
there are definitely are times that I
remember growing up and even now as an
adult where I feel like when my mom and
I talk about things that she sometimes
doesn't hear really like I have to say
something over and over and over and go
back to it and it's really hard for her
sometimes to hear something because it's
not what she wants to hear I have to see
my father he's what we call it a weekend
dead right cuz that's when we could go
visit him was every other weekend and
growing up he sat in front of the TV the
entire time and he wasn't a good
listener he wasn't someone that I ever
felt that I could come to for anything
really and he just feels that the world
owes him everything sometimes he would
call me literally as I'm in class and
I'm and I would text him and be like hey
I can't talk right now but this today
how come you're always so busy how come
you never have time for me it just got
to the point where he was making me feel
like complete garbage and he would say
hateful things to me and I was like you
know what out of all your children I'm
the only one that still talks to you and
I am trying to do the best that I can
and no matter what it was just never
good enough for him I feel so fortunate
to have the parents that I do anytime I
approach them with a problem I am hurt I
am supported and usually hugged so I
growing up I had so many people think
that I was missing out on something
because I didn't have a mom and that I
wouldn't be able to learn about like
what it is to be a woman or what it is
to you know have your period or whatnot
I had so many people approach me be like
oh I know you're missing a mother but
I'm always here if you want to talk and
I'm like no I can't talk about my
parents about that one of the biggest
things I believe in is you don't need a
mother you don't need a father you need
a parent my mother was also a single
parent she worked sometimes two jobs but
she was never too busy to talk to me she
was dead tired sometimes so what we did
was every Saturday we would hang out we
would clean the house first get dressed
get lunch and that was our time to talk
whatever was on my mind that was a good
time to bring it up so it let me know
that I could talk to her and that's what
I've done with David every Saturday we
David today when he was growing up so if
he wanted to eat McDonald's three times
a day we try to convince him for dinner
to eat something else but you get my
point
that it allowed him to speak freely it's
important that we continue to encourage
one another because you will keep us
young and we will be able to put some
wisdom on you you know and hopefully we
will listen to each other I think that
if everybody can just have moments where
they just tell their parents that they
love them have an honest conversation a
supportive conversation from both sides
I think that we need more of that thanks
so much for joining guys we really loved
revisiting this topic yeah it makes me
just wonder how you know we were like as
teenagers and our parents right don't
worry we are trying to revamp middle
ground if you guys have ideas of how to
revamp middle ground let us know DM us
email us comment below and we love to
hear from you guys all the time as usual
thanks for watching and we'll see you
guys around